police say the alleged mastermind in the
shooting of David Big Papi Ortiz is a
fugitive in the US and they now confirm
the Boston Red Sox legend was not the
intended target this new surveillance
video shows the attack in the Dominican
Republic
the fugitive suspect is identified as
Victor Hugo Gomez Milegi is in Santo
Domingo with where Ortiz was shot mullah
who was the gunman actually trying to
kill oh good morning Anthony yet we're
at the DI bar and lounge here in Santo
Domingo where the shooting happened more
than a week ago according to authorities
the intended target of the attack is a
friend of David Ortiz the two were
actually together the night of the
shooting in fact they were sitting right
here at the bar now what we know is that
the alleged mastermind ordered the hit
from inside the United States and that
the alleged gunman mistook for teens for
the man he was supposed to kill no
authorities in a new twist dominican
police revealed Wednesday that the true
intended target the night David Ortiz
was shot sat just feet away from him he
ain't gone Secutor z-- believe that this
man Victor Hugo Gomez planned it all and
that he meant to kill his own cousin
Sixto David Fernandez seen here
police say Ortiz and Fernandez were
wearing similar clothing the night of
the shooting yesterday prosecutors
warned Gomez is a dangerous fugitive
with a lengthy criminal history he's
believed to be a member of a major
Mexican drug cartel and is wanted by the
DEA he has been on the run in the United
States since March for a major drug
sting known as operation wrecking ball
Dominican officials believe Gomez wanted
revenge against Fernandez for ratting
him out for a drug offense eight years
ago
new surveillance video shows another
missing suspect an alleged middleman
Alberto Rodriguez Mota at the bar in the
hours leading up to the attack
authorities say he took this dark
picture of the intended target and
shared it with the other suspects
minutes later you can see him calmly
standing during the chaos last week the
alleged shooter Rafi Ferreira Cruz
reporters from his jail cell that he did
not mean to shoot or tease and was only
told what color of clothing to look for
we reached out to the DEA for comment on
Gomez and his alleged ties to drug
cartels but have not heard back 11
suspects are now in custody here in the
Dominican police continue to search for
at least three more including Gomez the
mastermind meanwhile David Ortiz
continues to recover we're said that he
is in good condition back in Boston Tony
all right mola eerie to see you there at
the bar now empty and a crime scene
thank you very much